The next question relates to a person
that is swallowing his or her own saliva
during the fast. Is this a permitted
act?
As far as swallowing the saliva is
concerned, it is a normal act. It's a
natural act.
And today science tells us that there
are
several liters of saliva being secreted
by the salivary gland every day.
And it is normal, it's natural
that the saliva a human being gulps it
down. He swallows it and this can't be
avoided. And Allah says in the Quran in
Surah Baqarah, chapter number two, verse
number 185, when it tells you that you
should fast for the full month of
Ramadan and those who are ill on a
journey they can
make up the period later on. Then it
says, Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
wants to make it easy for you and does
not want to put you in a difficulty.
Allah says in Surah Hajj, chapter number
22,
verse number 78, Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
does not want to give you hardship in
your deen, in your religion. So what
natural since following saliva is a
normal act
and I know that some people keep on
frequently spitting out and I have some
of my friends who do that thinking it's
haram to swallow and they keep on
spitting and imagine if you have to do
it the full day, you cannot even offer
your salah properly. Because when you
offer salah it takes a few minutes
and in few minutes also saliva gets
gathered. So will you be concentrating
on spitting the saliva out or on Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala? If you're reading the
Quran, you'll have to keep on spitting
outside always. And I know some people
who always keep uh maybe a container,
always spitting out, not knowing the
ruling. So if a person is swallows the
saliva, normal saliva which comes in the
mouth, it cannot be avoided at all. Same
way a person when he breathes the dust
with with the person goes to a city
which is polluted and there's dust
particles and you breathe that and some
of it goes in your lungs or it goes. So
it's all this is permissible because
this is a normal day-to-day act and
these do not violate your fast at all.